we're told that f of 7 is equal to 40
plus 5 e to the seventh power and F
prime of X is equal to five e to the X
what is f of zero so to evaluate F of
zero let's take the antiderivative of F
prime of X and then we're going to have
a constant of integration there so we
can use the information that they gave
us up here that f of 7 is equal to this
this might look like an expression but
it will it is an expression but it's
really just a number there's no
variables in this and so we can use that
to solve for our constant of integration
and then we will have fully known what f
of X is and we can use that to evaluate
f of 0 so let's just do it
so if F prime of X is equal to 5 e to
the X then f of X is going to be equal
to the antiderivative of F prime of X so
the antiderivative of 5 e to the X DX
and this is the thing that I always find
amazing about Exponential's and actually
let me just take a step I'll take that 5
out of the integral so it becomes a
little bit more obvious and so the
antiderivative of e to the X well that's
just e to the X because the derivative
of e to the X is e to the X which I find
amazing every time I have to manipulate
or take the derivative or antiderivative
of e to the X so this is going to be 5 e
to the X plus C and you can verify take
the derivative of 5 e to the X plus C
the derivative of 5 e to the X well
that's 5 e to the X so that works out
and the derivative well and the
derivative of C is 0 so you wouldn't see
it over here so now let's use now let's
use this information to figure out what
C is so that we know exactly what f of X
is and then we can evaluate f of 0 so we
know that F of 7 so when X is equal to 7
we're going to this expression is going
to evaluate to this thing 40 plus 5 e to
the 7 so 5 times e to the 7th power plus
C is equal to 40 is equal to 40 plus 5 e
to the 7th power and notice all I did is
that okay f of 7 well if this is f of X
f of let me write this down so if this
is f of 7
if this is f of X I just replace the X
with a seven to find F of seven and we
know that F of seven is also going to be
equal to that they gave us that
information but when you just look at
this it's pretty easy to figure out what
C is going to be you can subtract five e
to the seventh from both sides and you
see that C is equal to 40 and so we can
rewrite f of X we can say that f of X is
equal to five e to the X plus C which is
40 and so now from that we can evaluate
F of 0 F of 0 is going to be 5 times e
to the zero power plus 40 e to the 0 is
1 so it's going to be 5 times 1 which is
just 5 plus 40 which is equal to 45 and
we're done